esta vez tenemos una ecuación
diferencial que dice no se nos dé
2 esto que multiplican a de x igual a 2x
y nos dan una solución particular cuando
x es igual a 110 de 1 es igual a 0 y nos
piden que encontremos cuál es el valor
de x cuando james es igual a pi
así que lo primero que me gusta
preguntarme cuando veo una ecuación
diferencial es si es separable o no
puedo obtener las 10 y el de james de un
lado de la ecuación y las x de x del
otro lado de la ecuación
bueno pues viendo esta ecuación parece
que sí lo es si multiplicó ambos lados
por de x donde pueden ver de x como una
diferencial x de un cambio infinitamente
pequeño en x entonces obtienen un
siguiente vamos a obtener que el coche
no de james + 2 de que es igual a 2 x d
así que lo único que he hecho es
multiplicar de ambos lados de la
ecuación por de x y con esto fui capaz
de separar las 10 y las leyes de un lado
de la ecuación y las x y de x del otro
lado y ahora puedo integrar de ambos
lados entonces se integró de ambos lados
que voy a obtener bueno la anti derivada
de coser note que con respecto a james
es fácil es el seno de yema y luego
tengo el anti derivada de 2 con respecto
a james
eso es 2 james y esto va a ser igual
al anti derivada de 2x con respecto a x
que es x cuadrada y no podemos olvidar
la constante entonces esta es la
solución general para la ecuación
diferencia es separable y luego podemos
encontrar una en particular sustituyendo
cuando x es igual a 1 y es igual a 0
así que esta información nos va a ayudar
a encontrar hacer cuando que es igual a
x es igual a 1 tengo el 2 siguiente
tendríamos que el seno de 0 más 2 por 0
lo único que hice fue sustituirla por 0
en este punto esto va a ser igual a x
cuadrada pero ahora x es igual a 1
entonces me quedaría 1 al cuadrado más
bien seno de 0 0 2 por 0 0 así que todo
esto va a ser cero y entonces tenemos
que ser o es igual a 1 más sé que se me
es igual a menos 1 así que ahora podemos
escribir la solución particular para
esta ecuación diferencial separable que
cumple estas condiciones entonces
tenemos el seno de james + 2 james es
igual a equis cuadrada y nuestra
constante es igual a menos 1 entonces
menos 1 y ahora cuál es el valor de x
cuando james vale pib entonces vamos a
sustituir allí por pink y me quedaría
seno de pim
2 pink es igual a x cuadrada menos 1
ahora se nos de pies igual a 0 entonces
tenemos veamos 2 pib y si sumamos uno de
ambos lados tenemos dos primas uno igual
a equis cuadrada o podemos decir que x
es igual a más menos la raíz cuadrada de
dos primas 1 entonces ya está escribiré
aquí que x es igual aquí ya tengo el más
menos la raíz cuadrada de dos primas 1 y
qué creés hemos terminado